c'est non les chroniques de la haine
ordinaire
papa et
imaginez façon les membres yb lequel la
mouette sk gas l'un des plus beaux
palaces hôtel de genève un grand beau
cube adouci aux entournures cachant aux
yeux du populaire sous sa brillante
carapace de verres fumés des chambres de
princesses et des salons des bennes où
seul le cliquetis assourdi d'une
cuillère d'argent sur un cristal de dôme
où le froissement craquelé d'un billet
de 100 dollars viennent parfois troublé
à peine le silence feutré des moquettes
vers tente si profonde que les plus
petits émir chatouiller sous les bras
par le redoux kwal de l'aisne épurer les
parcours tant pouffant d'un beau rire
orientale j-20 dormir trois nuits au
frais de mon éditeur lequel ébloui par
le chiffre de mes tirages au seuil de
l'année nouvelle m'avait envoyé
ronronner là pour que je me partage as
entre deux interviews qu'on passait par
6 et 2 intervieweuse qu'on passait par
là avec des gros lots pour la partie
ludique au soir du troisième jour alors
que l'hôtel était bondé du nord de
gominés de parvenus de style vuitton
cartier atterries en ces lieux pour
assister à je ne sais plus quel salon de
la décoration de bureau pour amateurs
d'ordinateurs louis 15 voici qu'apparaît
est à la réception et à l'improviste un
magnifique ministre princier d'un état
du golfe avec une noble tête de pirates
du désert sur un ensemble balmain pied
de poule et un gorille élastiquée
camionnage beau comme un depardieu
rectifie au brou de noix cher
réceptionniste dit le ministre ou tara
les b alors famille à hawaii tamani
awarta latine plait-il s'étonna la
réceptionniste well i l'armoire d'après
cette date
i would like to get the room one hundred
averti m
le réceptionniste hélas du s'aplanir en
excuses navré la suite 138 celle que le
prince et son rookie des sables habitait
habituellement était exceptionnellement
occuper son altesse aurait dû réserver
mais il restait une chambre simple la
or le ministre exigeait que son garde du
corps dormi dans la même suite que lui
sur un lit de camp dans la pièce
contiguë
hélas ou là ou là cette nuit là non
seulement il ne restait qu'une chambre
mais tous les lits de camp avaient été
réquisitionnés pour les épouses et les
états ire des cadres brillantine et suse
décrit son altesse accepte rethel
exceptionnellement que son collaborateur
dormi à l'étagé du dessus ou restait une
chambrette mansardé sous le toit
il ya la hat betek hurla le ministre ce
qu'on peut traduire en substance par
[ __ ] de bordel de merde j ai nom de
dieu le réceptionniste affolé réveilla
le directeur le prince était le meilleur
client de l'hôtel
l'été ils venaient prendre les eaux du
lac avec son harem les cousines de son
harem les soeurs des cousines de soir m
et des tas de potes sous zémire
pétrolifères djellabi qu qui venait
déverser leurs milliards superflue par
les fenêtres du casino la seule exigence
de ce client en or étaient confie dormir
sont musclés près de lui je suis
infiniment confus dit le directeur
je ne vois qu'une solution ce serait que
monsieur ajoute-t-il en montrant la bête
humaine veuille bien couché dans le lit
de votre altesse dans le lit même de
votre altesse dans la chambre 147 je
ferai remarquer à votre altesse qu'il
s'agit d'un lit de 250 cm de large ce
qui exclut tout à toute éventualité de
promiscuité désobligeantes
n'est ce pas ajouta-t-il avec un accent
vaudois approximatif car il était de
berne hier à la rade betek rue la la
seigneurie signifiant qu'il n'était
absolument pas question qu'un prince de
sang s'allonge à jamais dans les mêmes
draps qu un roturier du même sexe
finalement c'est une petite soubrette
espagnol qui trouva la solution elle
suggéra timidement commis trois bras
dans le lit
le prince dans mireille entre le premier
et le deuxième devra le gorille entre le
deuxième et le troisième drame on
l'applaudît
on fit comme elle l'avait dit tout le
monde hormis bien cette nuit là le
prince n'est pas à pas la soubrette
mais il lui fit porter des fleurs tout à
fait merveilleuse qui la firent
s'émouvoir de ravissement cette fable
bien sûr ne vaut que parce qu'elle n'en
est pas une
elle est authentique et rassurante dans
la mesure où elle nous prouve qu'on a
souvent besoin d'un plus petit que soi
pour réussir le clivage des classes
sociales dans les contes à dormir
coucher quant au mois de mars y apprend
la bretèque je le dis sans aucune
arrière pensée politique
cela m'étonnerait qu'ils passent il est
[Applaudissements]
fait non
[Musique]